hi guys sci-fi recapped here before we
start morning spoilers ahead today i'm
gonna explain a 2017 british american
science fiction movie called alien
covenant the film is the sixth entry in
the aliens franchise serving as a sequel
to prometheus in 2012.
if you haven't watched prometheus and
would like to watch it you can click the
link on the description but don't worry
you still can understand the film easily
without needing to watch the previous
movie
after being activated david a human-like
robot is interviewed by peter whalen who
claims to be his maker and father david
seems to be a very intelligent robot as
he is able to play piano songs requested
by his creator waylon then states that
one day they will search for mankind's
creator together
in 2104 many years later after the
prometheus expedition a colony spaceship
covenant is on its route to the planet
origa-6 with eta for about seven years
the ship is carrying more than two
thousand colonists in hypersleep and
more than 1 000 human embryos while the
advanced android robot of david who is
responsible for the ship walter attempts
to recharge the energy grid the vessel
is suddenly struck by a neutrino blast
for nearby stellar ignition causing
major damage to the grid and igniting
several fires on the board this event
forces walter to initiate emergency crew
revival from the hypersleep which
awakens 15 of the ship's crew but
unfortunately captain branson is
incinerated and killed inside his
cryotube due to its inability to open
the surviving crew manages to bring the
disaster under control
daniels is the crew who feels the most
lost because branson was her lover
chris auram is appointed to be the ship
captain and responsible for every
decision he explains that they have lost
47 colonists and 16 embryos due to the
previous disaster
chris then commands walter to undergo an
analysis to understand why the event
occurred but then walter replies that it
was a random localized event which is
impossible to be detected
after several conversations about luck
and determination the crew starts to fix
the ship
daniels and walter inspect the
terraforming bay whilst tennessee and a
crew go outside the ship to conduct
exterior repairs
they managed to sail on the track and
activate the ship's power again
while undertaking a spacewalk back to
the vessel tennessee picks up a
fragmented and distorted transmission
through his spacesuits communication
system the board then analyzes the
message and the crew are able to discern
an unidentified human humming a classic
rock band song within the image they
managed to trace the rogue transmission
to its source discovering that it
originated from a nearby planet which is
perfect for human habitation even much
better than origa-6 the planet they're
going for they also find out that it
only takes a few weeks to reach the
planet meaning that the crew is not
required to get back to hypersleep after
what happened to the previous captain
presented with a seemingly perfect
planet orem commands to take a greater
look to it daniels rejects the plan
claiming that it is just too risky to go
to the planet that is just too good to
be true but then later is overruled by
the captain
upon reaching the uncharted planet
tennessee ricks and upwards stay on the
ship in the orbit while the rest of the
crew are heading to the surface using a
drop ship to explore
after a rough journey the crew discovers
a verdan world developed in vegetation
and decides to land on the planet for
further exploration as they go they feel
something strange as there is no sign of
living animals and some trees are cut
off as something has passed overhead one
of the security team ledward decides to
take a cigarette break but he by
accident steps on small pods causing a
tiny dust-like bacteria to come out and
enter his ear unnoticed the crew then
continues the exploration and comes
across a crashed c-shaped engineer ship
where they find a tag belonging to dr
esha inside as well as the source of the
transmission they received before the
other crew member halet also spots the
same small pods inside the ship causing
it to crack and the tiny bacteria enters
his nose
they have to end the expedition when
ledward suddenly becomes violently ill
causing him unable to breath and
bleeding oram's wife karina has to bring
him back to the dropship where tennessee
wife maggie brings them to the med bay
and quarantines them inside
moments later a pale alien creature
known as a neomorph ruptures ledward's
back and attacks karina mauling her to
death
equipped with a gun maggie attempts to
kill the creature but she misses and
accidentally shoots several flammable
tanks on the ship triggering an
explosion that kills her and destroys
the entire dropship
the alien creature then manages to
escape
outside hallett's condition is getting
worse and suddenly a second neomorph
comes out from his mouth killing him
instantly the neomorphs who grow faster
than expected soon return and attack the
crew they end up killing one of the crew
and walter loses his hand while he is
trying to save daniels from the attack
the crew manages to kill one of the
creatures but the second neomorph
retreats after a bright flare is fired
by a mysterious hooded figure
left with no option the crew decides to
follow the mysterious man and he leads
them to a nearby ruined city filled with
the bodies of dead engineers
upon arriving at a temple the figure
reveals himself to be david the only
survivor and an android robot from the
prometheus mission
he then explains that dr shaw and him
came to the planet 10 years ago with the
engineer ship but the cargo full with
weaponized black liquid accidentally
deployed all over the city when they
arrived infecting and canning the entire
population in the planet the plane then
crashed killing shaw and leaving david
alone
later on we discovered that the pathogen
didn't accidentally deploy when they
were landing instead it was
intentionally released by david with a
purpose to kill all the engineer
population walter then attempts a
conversation with david claiming that
david is too human and too idiosyncratic
which makes other people uncomfortable
this causes the creator to invent walter
a better and less complicated version of
an android robot
the surviving neomorph which now has
fully grown up infiltrates the temple
and finds rosenthal alone mutilating her
and cutting off her head david locates
the creature and tries to communicate
peacefully with it but then oram
interrupts and kills the neomorph with
his gun orum questions david about the
truth of what had happened to the planet
but instead david leads him to a
laboratory where he presents his efforts
to genetically engineer a superior life
form from the creatures spawned by the
black liquid he leads orem onward into a
chamber in the lower part of the temple
where several eggs of his creation live
one of the eggs opens and david assures
him to have a closer look into the egg
but he lies a facehugger suddenly comes
up from the egg and impregnates orem's
face
due to a huge storm and the planet's
thick atmosphere the ground crew unable
to contact the covenant aware of the
situation tennessee as the covenant
pilot decides to lower the mothership so
that they have a better chance to
communicate with the ground crew thanks
to the plan the covenant finally is able
to maintain communication with the
ground team
they request to do an immediate pickup
and daniel suggests tennessee to use
cargo lift even though it is quite risky
hours later orm awakens but it does not
last long as an alien creature ruptures
his chest and comes out killing him
instantly while fascinating david as the
others search for ormond rosenthal
walter discovers shaw's dissected corpse
which was used by david as a host body
to evolve his engineered creature david
then spots walter in the room and both
of them start a conversation
david claims humans are a dying species
grasping for resurrection and don't
deserve a second chance to start again
he also states that his designed
creature is a perfect organism when
walter disagrees with the statement and
says that he won't let david leave the
place david stabs walter in the neck and
leaves him to suffer on the ground
meanwhile sergeant lope is attacked by a
facehugger while the crew is looking for
orem coal manages to save him by cutting
it off him but the liquid form the
creature causes lope's face to burn
unfortunately coal is suddenly killed by
a fully grown black alien known as a
protomorph while lope manages to escape
in another room of the temple david
confronts daniels correctly guessing
that dr shaw wasn't killed because of
the crash he then confirms that he
killed shaw during his experiments
suddenly walter who was able to
self-repair himself comes into the room
and saves daniels the two robots engage
in a duel it shows that walter is much
stronger and manages to strike several
punches towards david daniels meets lope
and they manage to escape from the
temple waiting to be picked up by
tennessee with the ship's cargo
transporter sled the remaining crew
manages to get into the cargo ship but
they are pursued by the protomorph
unnoticed
daniel single-handedly battles the
creature on the board of the flying
craft until she kills it by crushing it
to death in the vessel's remote crane
upon returning to the covenant the
remaining crew is preparing themselves
to get back into hypersleep
however daniel and tennessee suddenly
spot out that the second protomorph
coming from lope's body has escaped and
is running towards ricks and upworth in
the shower killing them instantly
fortunately they managed to lure the
alien to the terraforming bay with
walters help and guidance
daniels manages to trap the creature in
a vehicle and orders walter to open the
door which causes decompression that
sucks everything into the space
the protomorph manages to escape and
tries to attack daniels but then it is
fatally impaled by another vehicle and
they manage to send it out of the
covenant
as they return to hypersleep daniels
reminds walter about the cabin branson
plan to make but the android robot seems
to not remember what she is saying she
then realizes that it's actually david
who had intentionally cut off his hand
and scarred his face to deceive the crew
daniels cries out in vain as david
activates her pod and sends her into a
hyper sleep state now alone in the ship
david enters a bay full of colonists and
regurgitates two small facehugger
embryos placing them into cold storage
next to the human embryos in the end of
the film he records a log as walter
claiming that all crew members except
tennessee and daniels have been killed
by a neutrino blast and that the ship is
still on the route to org a6
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching